the chapter that you are supposed to be
contemplating this week is called the
new Power Balance it's one of a sequence
of three chapters that have the word new
on them which is very creepy because
history is a in the sense what's new in
history it's all happened a long time
ago but nevertheless this new Power
Balance has an even more enigmatic word
in the title and that is the word power
because the chapter divides into two
pieces the first piece is a
technological piece and the second piece
is a political piece and to say the
first of the technological piece deals
with steam telegraphy electricity steel
chemistry etc focusing on Europe as the
locus of invention of things and the
second focuses on changes in the
political arena particularly the
unification of Germany and Italy and
then the the opening of Japan with the
Meiji Restoration almost literally new
powers as opposed to simply a new Power
Balance as opposed to an old power
balance but rather a balance of new
powers with respect to the existing
array of powers so we're going to talk
today primarily about the technological
piece of the chapter and
what I've been pondering a lot is why
does any any population group think that
they're just way way better than all the
others and it may not seem like a very
difficult question because you know
there's so many different examples of it
being clearly at some point there were
people in Muslim society with a great
prosperous Empire who thought well we
have a religion that makes us better
than anyone else or you had a Chinese
society with great prosperity and
productivity and so we we're the we're
the Middle Kingdom we are better than
anyone else or you had a society of
conquerors well they were the
Macedonians and Greeks under Alexander
the Great or the Mongols under Genghis
Khan or the conquistadores in the new
world say well we're better than anyone
else because we can we can win all the
wars we are in and of course what you
realize in history is that all of these
all these claims to to be the
exceptional you know the out of the
ordinary the the superior all of them
come to an end
I mean this is after all the almost a
given of history is that all greatness
is fleeting sort of the look on my works
ye mighty and despair the line of
Ozymandias that Shelley wrote
hypothesizing the feet of a fallen
statue somewhere in the Egyptian sands
so even though everyone knows if they
study history that the notion of being
the best of the superior the the
standard against which everyone else is
tested and falls short everyone knows
that this is a transitory phenomenon
until it comes to modern Europe and then
there is a much more elaborated argument
that posits modern Europe as truly an
exception not simply temporarily the
richest or with the best religion and
are the strongest armies but but
something truly extraordinary that is
unexampled in other lands and other
histories and that this is sort of the
pivot around which all history must
ultimately turn or it's the Telos toward
which all history ultimately leads and
the number of ways in which European
advocates of European Exceptionalist
articulate this is as legion it's
possible that it's true and that what
happened in Europe in the 18th 19th
centuries
was so different that that the
superiority of the European system or
whatever was cannot be gained set I mean
it is simply there it's a truth it's a
fact and efforts to prevent lies it or
to diminish it or to say well you know
Europe got there first but you know
Egypt and Namibia were on their way and
you know there's nothing that special
other than Europe being first to certain
things arguments that are made but seem
to be rather Hollow
and so I found myself wondering well is
there some warrant here is there is it
something that happened that was
categorically different from other
historical phenomena and I look at
different arenas and I think well
science is important yes but maybe it
doesn't quite effect enough of society
to be a key military superiority comes
and goes the European certainly had it
they don't have it anymore
prosperity well yeah but there have been
other prosperous societies and
prosperity is is something that is
realized in a competitive context and at
some point others some other country is
going to be more prosperous than yours
modernity
that's the enigmatic term whatever it
might mean
yet this is when it gained head weight
so I got thinking about this
technological side of it and I thought
well is it the technology that would
warrant this and of course there are
many technologies and therefore you have
to do specify what you mean that seems
to me that to stand out and that the key
to them both is is velocity the ability
to make something go faster now ever
since humans first started trekking Out
of Africa the fundamental rate of
velocity has been walking that is how
you perceive a landscape that is how you
you sense the distances that you're
covering people would walk from place to
place up through the 18th century
walking remained for for Europe as well
as most of the world of the most common
way of of getting around and even if you
had a animal you could ride or a cart
then you could ride in the velocity at
which would go wasn't that wasn't all
that different from from the the pace of
which a good walk a camel caravan
travels about the pace of humans walking
whether it's across the Sahara desert
across Central Asia Arabia wherever it
is that Caravan that carries you know
thousands of animal loads of precious
Goods is is going as fast as you can
walk so then if you get tired of riding
on a camel you simply get off and you
walk and you will keep up with it you
see someone riding a donkey well you
couldn't walk pretty much as fast and
that donkeys going to going to go maybe
the donkey will outpace you a little bit
a horse now there's a faster animal so
long as it wishes to keep riding fast
but the the speed at which you could
send a message on horseback doesn't
change very much from the first imperial
postal system of the Achaemenid z-- back
in the fifth one IAM bc and the Pony
Express which comes to an end in 1863
it's true a fast horse with a relay set
up so you can keep shifting from one to
another can get you from one place to
another fairly quickly and certainly
faster than you can walk but most people
don't have fast horses never did and
those people who who have the most
horses say the Central Asian nomads also
have you know tens of thousands of sheep
well you know you can't get on your
horse and then all the horsemen sort of
ride off and the meat for the Sheep to
catch up does the Sheep don't know where
you're going and can't keep them their
mind and know you're still going as fast
as the Sheep can walk a sheep walks
really slow I recall being stuck with my
bicycle in a narrow path behind a bunch
of sheep boy do they go slow really
really slow
Patera you know very impatient to get
around those sheep particularly cuz one
of them was dying and the Shepherd kept
beating it with a stick trying to get it
to walk into town before it died
so the the way in which the world was
experienced was fairly slow now it'll be
a little different if you were in a boat
but then you know what's there to see
you know water it's really the land the
perception of the of the land that I'm
thinking of here people could have gone
faster earlier than they did that is to
say we have we know of people who
developed something sort of a prototype
of the bicycle going back to the 17th
18th century but you've never had never
caught on I mean that the whole notion
was that everything in the world is
moving in a certain at a certain pace
and you have the exceptions that pace
but they simply aren't that many then
you had the railroad and I would argue
that the railroad is the most
fundamental change in human perception
of the world they live in that you have
from Paleolithic times down to modern
times what I mean by perception of the
world you live in when you change the
rate at which you experience the world
it it changes I would say your
perception of many things and we became
from the railroads on connoisseurs of
speed
no if you had a horse race or a a
chariot race or a carriage race down to
the 18th century you were interested in
which of these vehicles can go faster
which driver is more adroit keeping the
animals under control but you weren't
racing against an absolute standard in
other words if there been a Guinness
Book of World Records and they say you
know how fast was the fastest carriage
journey a very hard time finding any
records there are some they would say
well on such-and-such a day you know the
trip from Bristol to London was made by
a stagecoach and so many hours and that
was a bit faster than the previous known
trip but the idea of that that that
velocity would be a goal and that that
goal could be attained by everyone
really wasn't there when you look at
say 18th 19th century European travelers
even going back to to the late
Renaissance one of the common things you
find among artists and among travelers
who have a an eye to sketching things
his vistas and one of the ones common
vistas is the Vista of a city you know
usually on a hillside sometimes not and
you know it's a drawing and you see the
city and the distance everything is
something like you know El Greco's view
of Toledo or something like that
oh this these sort of vistas were done
by any number of European artists
sometimes I imagine them for example
going to know Rome or some other
artistic destination
and getting to the point where they see
the hurt they see the city on the
horizon they just walked over the hill
and they stopped say well let's look at
this Vista and then they draw it and it
strikes me every time I come into Boston
from the West and I see say the
potential Tower say oh there's Boston
zip 70 miles per hour
and the Vista is gone or coming into
Chicago from O'Hare Airport say ah
there's the Sears Tower oh no L salute
we just we went past at 70 miles an hour
you don't stop because the speed at
which you're going has turned the
immediate landscape into essentially a
blur you've become much more oriented
toward the the the terminus than the
pathway
let's say when you read books that deal
with the sort of cultural tours that
began to be stylish
back then we in the 17th century where
someone would go and spend two or three
years travelling through Europe and
gaining an education they walked from
place to place and they perceived not
simply the terminus so they go to but
the ends on the way or the villages or
the people in the livestock and the
local costumes and so forth and so on it
doesn't all just whizzed by localism is
a hallmark of this sort of pedestrian
life because most people did not I'm not
going to say do not but did not say in
the 18th century ever travel more than
let us say 25 miles from the place of
birth most people lived in villages or
on farms and it would be rare for them
to travel travel very far the work and
the countryside did not give them the
leisure to do it when it took so long
and people who traveled given the pace
of which they traveled frequently
traveled with the expectation or with
the the question as to whether they
would ever go where they had ever come
home again I mean if you join the army
or found yourself waking up with a
hangover and on it one of Her Majesty's
ships and therefore had joined the Navy
or if you join the caravan or if you
made the pilgrimage to Mecca or to Rome
or wherever when you started on a
journey
it wasn't clear whether that journey
would be the pathway of your life and
you would go from here to there
and then you would be there and you
would stay there or you would go beyond
there but the idea of sometimes I
thought about the history of human
motion I think of you have journeys to
journeys fro and journeys to and fro
like a journey to might be a pilgrimage
a journey fro might be a migration to a
new land journeying to and fro is
uncommon because how could you expect
realistically to to get through the
vicissitudes of a journey that might if
you were going say to China or the new
world something like that get to the
visit of the vicissitudes of something
of a journey that might take three or
four five years when you look at people
even in the 18th century sometimes it'll
stand out and you'll read the biography
let's say he made the trip to the new
world from England he went from England
to the colonies seven times we have
people now who do it seven times a week
and we fail to appreciate that probably
on each of those journeys there was the
wondering whether they would ever ever
come back again an awful lot of people
never came back one of the most common
types of lawsuits that you have in
Ottoman law is the lawsuit by a woman
whose husband went off on the war and
never returned and can she get him
declared dead so that his estate can be
distributed and she can remarry because
there was no return
and information went at the same speed
as the person on foot or on horseback
with very uncertain reliability I mean
when someone comes back from the wars
and you say oh did my John survive the
war um I can't remember know just been
terribly frustrating because people move
slowly information moves slowly and the
Train changed that and the Telegraph
changed and I would say that the the
change in velocity for people and for
information was a truly profound
transformation
the railroad is an improbable invention
it's you when you think of how things
could have been screwed up not to have
the railroad it's fairly easy you have a
situation where where you have a very
very heavy source of power and you put
it on a on a rolling platform george
stephenson who was the pioneer of the
railroad was the son of a coal mine
worker in the Newcastle area and eastern
coast of England he had no education he
are very little education the mines the
coal mines were the main work that was
available so he worked in the mines and
various capacities
among those pack capacities was to be a
brakeman on the the hoisting device used
to to move a hoist up and down the mine
that could be operated by a steam engine
the first you know significant
application of steam engines was to
mines where you could build a large
stationary engine and you had a use for
the for the engine because it could pump
water out of the mine that could operate
a hoist so he learned about steam
engines in the coal mines and he also
experienced the fact that inside the
mine you had wooden tracks with metal
surfaces on them and you had heavy carts
or having wagons with four wheels and
steel wheels
and this was very important because the
the most friction-free
form of common form of rolling transport
is steel on steel anything else and
every time you start up you're sort of
digging yourself out a kind of a ditch
but steel on steel or iron on iron has
very little friction and for a mine
where you have these carts full of coal
or or two that they devised the idea
that that this was the way they can move
this coal most easily in the mine so
they would have a pony pulling up or a
human so now you have a confluence of
first of mines that have to be pumped in
supposing the coal in England had been
near the surface like central Illinois
and they could have just strip mined it
instead of digging digging down but you
had mines that needed to be pumped
since there were since the mines were
not generally in a position to use power
that would come from a water mill the
steam engine could do it no matter how
cumbersome and awkward it was the steam
engine operated by burning coal well
what good luck it's the coal mines that
you have not iron mines not compromised
but the coal was right there then you
have a transportation system in the mind
that maids a great deal of sense for
moving the coal within the mine and has
a four wheeled vehicle on a on a track
george stephenson built a railroad where
he put a steam engine on a rolling
platform and pulled ore carts or coal
carts for miles
uphill at six miles an hour twice as
fast as you could walk and that was the
first first railroad first railroad was
not designed to carry people it was
precisely the confluence of the the coal
the pumping the steam engine for the
pumping the rail and wheel combination
than you had in the mine and one
person's idea of how to how to do this
all right from there you get a very very
rapid transition to the idea of a
passenger railroad passenger railroads
became a craze the rate of railroad
building throughout the same middle
third of the 19th century it's
absolutely extraordinary
why were railroads so so mesmerizing I'd
argue it's because they went fast and
one of the things that you find when you
when you read books going back to that
period or from the early times of
motorcars is people commenting on what
it's like to go fast I mean boy you know
12 miles an hour you know I you know
could hardly catch my breath because of
the phenomenal speed of which we were
moving or 40 miles an hour oh geez
40 miles an hour that's that was the
speed typically that my parents would
drive when I was young and we'd go on
family trips and you say well over 40
you know it just isn't safe to drive
over 40 40 is just about right but 40 by
the standard of 1920s would have been
really fast the speed goes up and up
what's the railroads that introduced the
speed off the motor cars and not the
carriage
and people develop a fascination with
with moving fast this is the first
acceleration really significant
acceleration no like numerous multiples
of walking speed that ever occurred from
Paleolithic times onward
it happened in steamships earlier
because you have seen ships at the turn
of the 19th century where as the
railroads don't come in until the 1840s
but the but the steamship didn't
necessarily seem to move a whole lot
faster than a sailing vessel sailing
vessel could move fast or slow depending
on the winds steamship had more reliable
but the efficiency of the propulsive
system for steam ships was not enormous
so you didn't you could have steam boat
races and did have steam boat races
eventually but the the perception of
extreme speed really came from the
railroad partly I think because the in a
railroad the scenery was right next to
you whereas on a riverboat you were
looking at a river bank that might be
you know hundred meters away or if you
were at sea you didn't have any
comparison to tell how fast you were
going
though the railroad you were going
through going fast and people thought of
themselves as going fast there were two
other inventions that played a role in
this and both of them are significant
from this point of view of velocity one
of them is the clock
if you were going to build a railroad
with trains going in two directions you
could either build two tracks or rather
four tracks two pairs of tracks and
allow the trains to pass each other as
they won't go back and forth or you
could build one track problem with
building two tracks was that you have
had to have twice as much capital twice
as much labour it twice as much land so
most of these railroads were single
track railroads what you don't want to
have happen on a single track railroad
is two trains going in opposite
directions at the same time because
head-on collisions did occur and it was
very important to try and do everything
you could to avoid them the key to this
was was time was to have a schedule the
invention of clocks goes back to the
medieval period in Europe and many
people have talked about how important
timekeeping is for the Industrial
Revolution so that people would you know
go to go to work or come home from work
when the when the whistle sounded in the
factory and they would you know the
dinner bell also and summon people to
meals but it didn't have to have a clock
behind it you don't need to have a clock
in order to get people do something at
the same time the paramount historian of
timepieces David Landis argued that the
necessity for the clock comes from the
monks who had to get up at certain
specified times in order to say the mass
and if for some reason he doesn't seem
to grasp that Muslims have to pray five
times a day Jews have to pray certain
times a day monks aren't the only people
who have to get up in the middle of the
night and so there's no there's a
particular reason why monastic hours
would be determining here particularly
when the monastic hours are affected as
are the Muslim hours of Prayer by the
changing seasons and the length of the
day I mean if you have to pray at dawn
you don't have a clock that you would
just have to change the date of the time
of dawn in the course of the year so the
whole religious rationale doesn't make
much sense
the clocks appear to of the early clocks
appear to been used more as ceremonial
devices where you have a clock in a Town
Square and on the hour the clock would
chime and that would come a little
parade of you know soldiers and you know
the prince and his retinue and so forth
and they go around the glockenspiel the
clock play and you'd play chimes or
something like that very frequently
historians kind of mock Chinese court
culture for saying well they they got
clocks from the Jesuits but they treated
them as if they were toys well thank you
that's what the way they were being used
and right down to the 19th century we
have a lot of evidence that someone who
had a clock that was say a pocket watch
wore it on Sunday then wear it every day
was an expensive thing it was a
showpiece you hung it where it's visible
it was a sign of your of your status we
know now that in the
1790s Chinese did exactly the same thing
that they had both European and Chinese
made clocks and instead of having a a
weskit of a chain to hang the clock from
they had ornamental jade hooks it would
hook on their girdle and then hook the
clock to it so you would everyone can
see you had a clock it's the same sort
of upwardly mobile aspiration that you
had in Europe at that time
we even have one memoranda strum yang
Chow in China who comments that it seems
that people who have clocks still are
late for meetings and that the clock
really wasn't changing anything so you
had only two professions in which the
clock proved to be important at least
early on the first of them was seafaring
because you had to have accurate Seaborn
clocks in order to determine the
longitude because you were setting one
that was supposed to be set accurately
at the time from your place of departure
and then you would have that for
comparison for the longitude and there
was a prize for that and the prize was
won and people were able to determine
longitude at sea but on the land
nobody's very interested in longitude
this was primarily an issue for
seafarers to know how far they had gone
at sea it's the railroad that brings the
clock in to the end of the arena of a
necessity and railroad time comes to be
the synonymous with accurate time
and the image right up through the 1940s
of the the conductor pulling his pocket
watch out and looking at it and then
saying all aboard I mean that that was
what his schedule was prior to the
railroads what was the point of having a
schedule how did he keep to a schedule
stayed coaches didn't have a schedule
they left when they were able to leave
and they arrived when they arrived
business hours yeah he kept business
hours
however he wished you could keep them
strictly or you could keep them loosely
but he didn't need to have a clock to to
schedule it but once you had the clock
become necessary to avoid head-on
collisions and railroads then you also
had a very clear interest in actually
recording velocities you know you had a
reason to know how fast something was
going
the these experiences of the railroad
era were to some degree replicated when
automobiles came along but it's
important to to realize that these
things that are happening in the 1840s
have no there's no capacity of anyone at
that time to to conceive of how this
might be transferred off the rails that
is to say to something like a truck or a
passenger vehicle what this meant was
that as the railroads spread the notion
of a railroad terminus became became
crucial because every railroad terminus
was in a sense the the nucleus of a of a
distribution system where you would have
roads going out you had offload people
or cargo onto wagons and those wagons
would be carry would carry the goods
wherever they were wherever they were
going at one point my great-grandfather
sold
pianos to farmers door-to-door in
southern Indiana that many had to carry
a grand piano on a wagon from one farm
to another but that was that was normal
when you you had the notion of the
Traveling Salesman is really a product
of the of the railroad era before that
you had peddlers you know if peddlers
going back for hundreds of years people
would carry their stock on their back
have a frame and they would carry a big
pack and many notable individuals
started their lives as peddlers of the
original
a founder of the Guggenheim family I was
a peddler working out of Philadelphia
and he would carry lightweight things
that housewives needed like ribbon and
thread needles and pins and things like
that because you couldn't carry a whole
lot as a peddler
or else.you you carried your goods
simply to a single market where people
came into the market but but the
railroad now made the notion of being a
rail terminus a crucial distinction
between town a and town B places that
developed a very dense network of
railroads would try and connect every
every town through the railroad other
places the railroad would only go to two
major cities and then goods will be
distributed from there so so the the the
contrast between the fast motion you had
on the railroad and then the wagon
carrying you on a dirt road away from
the from the railroad station
was was striking and of course as well
as with Airlines the first people to
travel the railroads were people who
wanted the sensation of traveling fast
on the railroad and who could reward to
pay for it some people in this room will
remember when going on an airplane map
that you you dressed up you didn't want
to look like a slump on an airplane you
wore coat and tie and you didn't wear
you know Levi's and a t-shirt on the
airplane that would just be tacky nude
how you expect a nice meal and I expect
the
cabin service to be properly dressed and
so forth because it was a traveling an
airplane was experienced the actual
travel in the airplane was the
experience it wasn't just getting from
one place to another but you weren't
seeing anything in a sense though I
recall the first time I ever was an
airplane and we went into a cloud
thought my god what happens when you're
in a cloud no can you see anything in
the cloud and you know when was last
time I noticed whether I was in the
cloud in an airplane it's been a little
while now but this whole the whole
notion of of going fast as being a
status marker is something that that we
haven't lost it in other words when the
SST was around that was a status marker
if you could you know to go from you
know JFK to know
to France or to England in you know 30
minutes or whatever you know that was a
classy thing to do but the experience of
of speed was also as I say an experience
of landscape and begins to change the
way in which people value places know a
place with a train station was more
important than a place that did not have
a train station and if the railroad was
built in a bypass to your town this was
a this was a tragedy or else it was a
way of protecting you from from that new
world of speed so if you go to Cambridge
in England the railroad station was
deliberately built a long way from the
University in order to I mean nobody
wanted the lads to go down to London
they should be at college and so you put
the railroad station some distance way
or if you ever try and go to Princeton
where you take you get off at Princeton
Junction then you take a dinky into
Princeton because the train station is
not going to be built at the University
this sort of thing also affected when
interstate highways came in whether or
not you wanted to have an exit near your
near your city and you would think well
of course you want to have an exit but
then people thought no because that
would bring a lot of traffic and that it
would sort of destroy the character of
our of our city I come from a city where
we did not want to have an exit on the
interstate so the exit was built about
50 miles out of town then the whole city
moves out to be around the exit from the
interstate I'm I'm giving these sort of
random examples because I find it very
hard to to sort of encapsulate what this
this sense of a changed velocity may
have been liked but one of the things
that's more concrete is that the me I'm
leaving aside the the passenger element
of it so the exchange of goods is
accelerated you can move a greater
weight of goods from point A to point B
faster and back from point B to point a
faster than you ever could before in
human history
so those places that have railroads were
able to engage in commerce in a
completely new way emblematic of this
was the fact that when Europeans went
into non-western parts the world and
invested in railroads they typically
would build railroads to carry goods to
a seaport where they could be loaded
onto a European steamship and exported
rather than to connect key points within
that of that particular colony so
business speeds up the investment in the
railroad made in many instances depend
on the notion of a joint-stock company
and therefore grow out of the capitalist
background by the other hand you could
have railroads that are built without
that the technique of building a
railroad was a was a technological one
not one that was necessarily financial
so the first railroad that was built in
in Russia was ordered by the Czar paid
for by the Tsar he wanted a railroad
from Moscow to st. Petersburg and he
wanted it straight he did not want any
curves on his railroad so they built the
railroad from Moscow to st. Petersburg
in a perfectly straight line because
that was what the Tsar wanted the
technology
you know the engineers who designed the
railroad were foreigners as they were in
so many other areas but the railroad was
did not require a joint-stock company or
something in order to to finance it
James McNeill Whistler --zf ah there was
a chief engineer on the Russian railway
that was built so when he studied art
he's an American artist but but he
learned his art staying at a
conservatory in st. Petersburg and spent
most of his career in and in Europe this
from a biography entitled whistlers
father which I read because I thought it
was an acute title so so you have time
you have space and then you have the
question the movement of infrared of
information the telegraph develops at
about the same time as the railroad and
they are not exactly twins in other
words you could regulate the passage of
trains by a timetable to avoid
collisions you could also do it if you
built a telegraph line parallel to the
track
you could simply signal from one station
to another when the train had left and
that would be another way of determining
of making sure that you do not have
something untoward happened on the
tracks the telegraph had been a project
under development for 450 years by the
time you finally get to workable
versions that are associated with
different people in different countries
in this country primarily by Samuel FB
Morse and Alfred Vail his unacknowledged
co-inventor
the idea of the Telegraph is not as
novel as as the railroad and us to say
the the concept of moving information
rapidly as opposing as opposed to moving
people or goods rapidly that's a concept
that we see glimpses of off and on in in
earlier history for example when when
the Trojan War ends and you have signal
fires that carry the information to
Mycenae that that Agamemnon is on his
way back to his death that notion of
signal fires immortalized more probably
in part 2 of the Lord of the Rings movie
where it really works well the notion of
signal fires has been there for a long
time in the 18th century the French were
at the pinnacle of military technology
they have the best engineers the best
organized armaments industry the best
fortress designers
and they developed the idea of the
military semaphore military semaphore
consisted of towers within sight of one
another that would have arms that would
stick out at different angles usually
two arms and the angle at which the arm
was situated or the arms were situated
would indicate a letter of the alphabet
or maybe some emergency notification the
precursor of this would have been flag
signals between ships where you would
have a line on which you would suspend
flags that would indicate no messages to
go from one ship to another or if you
were close enough you could actually
have someone with crossed but with the
signal flags who would indicate an
alphabetic communication so it wasn't
purely by land but the idea of sending
information fast was seen as a military
necessity the alternative of course was
sending a messenger and there's a whole
cult of of the dispatch rider and they
you know the remarkable skills and
talents of fast messengers but the
semaphore was a you know a more
technically sophisticated system the
problem is that it had two that it went
on the assumption that you were sending
a message from a from one known place to
another known place and of course and
the vagaries of war where you happen to
be may not be where you have access to a
semaphore system but any event you have
these semaphores
developed
and at the same time you had people at
the turn of the 18th century who we
annual experiment with with electricity
and the question with electricity in
those days was basil it was basically
static electricity it was known as we
all know that you know if you you know
rub your feet on the carpet in the
middle of the winter and then touch
someone you'll get a spark and that's
the static electricity it was discovered
that if you that you could store that
sort of electricity no Leyden jar and if
you if somebody touched the pole of the
Leyden jar release that electricity and
you'd get a shock by the 1790s it was
there was that there was a French
clergyman who got monks or other clergy
people he could control to sit in a
circle with about you know a very large
diameter like a mile in circumference
and had a big Leyden jar and one person
touched a Leyden jar they were all
touching each other and then you could
observe that the that the shock that was
felt by the person farthest away from
the Leyden jar was occurring apparently
at the same time as the initial touching
of Leyden jar and that's what first gave
the idea of that electricity or one of
the first things they gave the idea that
electrical impulses travel essentially
instantaneously
well instantaneous movement is is very
appealing so then the question was how
could you apply that to to the transfer
a transmission of information between
1800 and
the late 1830s you have probably a store
of different inventors from a whole
bunch of different countries who are
experimenting with how to use
electricity this way though this is not
electrical current of alternating
current that's simply what you have the
static electricity buildup in a Leyden
jar although they eventually in this
process discovered that an electrical
impulse traveling through a wire created
a magnetic field and that led to the
development of the electromagnet
additionally they had schemes like well
if we have 26 letters in the alphabet
and we have 26 wires running from place
a to place B then we can send a message
by simply treat it you know putting
electrical charge through each wire
according to the alphabet that's a and
many of these schemes were really kind
of preposterous and they tended to be
developed in somebody's somebody's flat
take it okay I'm going to build a
telegraph that goes from my bedroom to
the kitchen and where maybe you could
put up 26 wires but it was very slow
careful until they finally get on the
idea of that um if the charge triggers
electromagnet the electromagnet could
cause a receiver to click first they
thought they would have to print that
out and then they realize that an
operator could actually just listen to
the clicks and decipher what the what
alphabetic message was conveyed the code
we use is called Morse code it's been a
historical dispute as to whether it was
actually devised by Morse or by his
colleague Vail
who had been his partner for a long time
and then wrote to him and said you know
I can no longer support the Telegraph
industry because it cannot support me
because he wasn't paid enough money
although he made some crucial
developments uh once they had a an
effective system the telegraph spread
with the same alacrity and enthusiasm as
the railroad so now you could move both
information and humans and goods at
velocities that had never before been
been conceived of now the reason I think
this is it's not only the first
transcontinental telegraph the United
States was 1861 and it was first message
was sent by Brigham Young Anderson
governor of the Utah Territory now the
reason I think this is these things are
linked together in importance is because
the movement of information has that
same impact on the conduct of business
affairs that the movement of good that
goods have other words you know in the
beginning of Merchant of Venice you have
the Italian merchant is waiting on the
Rialto in Venice for his ship to come in
will he have made a profit or not made a
profit would have been better if he
could have gone to the telegraph office
and found out whether his ship was ever
going to come in or whether it was sunk
at sea once you can communicate
instantaneously the transaction of
financial affairs it is accelerated
again it's a question of velocity only
now it's not a velocity of people and
goods it's a velocity of money
what we have seen in the last 10 or 20
years the idea of a 24-hour
instantaneous you know industry devoted
to moving money around the world is the
product of this Telegraph system and
what it basically allows as far as I can
see is that it becomes it and the
transport of goods they become
multipliers and that whatever wealth
there is is multiplied by the ability to
move goods faster and the ability to to
communicate orders and pay pay for
things and K on investments and at a
much faster rate so even without a
theory of capitalism which is derive
initially from from protecting people
against risk in a pre industrial
industrial trading society and then
takes on a strong industrial aspect with
Adam Smith and his successors where
labor is brought in as a primary
component but even in a in a non
capitalist society once you bring in
once you have raised the velocity of the
transmission of goods and people and
raised the velocity even more the
transmission of money the the wealth of
that place is now effectively multiplied
because you can have the same amount of
money but it can be applied to more
transactions per given period of time
but it never could before
so it seems to me that one of the things
that resulted in all this from these
changes in the velocity of human affairs
was that Europe became or Europe or
Europeans
society became permanently richer they
didn't have more they didn't necessarily
manufacture more goods Lord knows we
don't manufacture any Goods anymore they
didn't necessarily have more resources
no they would go on somewhere and find
more resources I didn't necessarily have
a more skilled population but their
ability to to move Goods people and and
information and money at greatly excess
to accelerate velocities multiplied the
the fundamental tools multiplied the
wealth through these tools so
there are many things that get
associated with this in other words once
you have these increases in in wealth
then you can do certain things with them
and some of these are associated with
the idea of modernity for example it's
been argued many times that consumer
commodity production and sales of things
for advertising and stores and so on is
something that comes out of the
Industrial Revolution
that probably is not the case it's now
been argued for example that the notion
of fashion the notion of continually
changing styles that where you would
have to you know change your clothes not
because they've worn out but in order to
be in style but that's something that
that really begins with in Europe at
least with printing and with the
publication of images that allow people
to don't to look at fashion as a
important component it doesn't depend on
the Industrial Revolution similarly it's
increasingly recognized that even in in
China in the late Ming period before
1600 that fashion and changing clothing
styles were you know had many of the
same connotations of class and
competition and modish 'no sand so forth
that that europe had so some things get
attached to this this idea of a modern
industrial world
that are probably not entirely
appropriate but because the problem is
like we call it an industrial world we
talk about industrialization my feeling
is that it's a high-velocity world and
that where the goods are made and how
they are made is less important than the
rate at which you could move them from
from place to place or the rate at which
you could transact the businesses and
conclude the contracts that provided for
the production and sale of these goods
why did industrialization become the
buzzword why do we talk about industrial
society or a pre-industrial society or
the non industrialized world this is
where I think the European notion of
absolute superiority was somewhat myopic
the assumption was that the ability to
be an industrial country was had kind of
an implicit genetic component to it and
that this was something the Europeans
had the cleverness and the the
imagination and the discipline to do and
lesser people did not as someone who's
read a lot of stuff in the Middle East
one of the patterns I've noticed is that
early travelers will go to a certain
area and they'll say the local people do
not understand something mechanical at
all you know they'll you show them an
object and they'll have no idea of what
it is or how to use it and they're
completely clumsy they're you know they
simply have no no technical skills then
you go a generation farther maybe two
generations they say it's amazing how
these local people knowing nothing are
able to imitate
the goods that we bring you know we
bring in a matchlock pistol and they'll
make an imitation of a matchlock pistol
and it works because they're kind of
like monkeys know if they know how to
imitate you know monkey see monkey do
and before they weren't even up to the
monkey lunar up to that level then you
go to the point you say you know they
actually invent their own things but you
know they're trivial things they're you
know pet rocks or you know cheap cheap
goods in particular they're not really
important goods this was sort of the
take on Japan after World War two when
you have cheap Japanese imports until
the until the transistor radios and Sony
Walkman start to come from Japan then
people said you know the Japanese unlike
other people in the world who are not
European actually have many of these
same talents that Europeans have the ANA
was discovered that they had those
talents in Hong Kong too I don't know
why Taiwan they have them too pretty
soon almost everyone was getting a free
pass into the world of industrial
invention except of course the Muslims
who are always at the bottom of the of
the creativity heap but even now Turkey
with the Anatolian Tigers you know well
maybe the Turks are different from other
Muslims of their religion hasn't ruined
them in the way at house I don't know
but gradually the Europeans took this
attitude of superiority and inch by inch
by inch they they began to back down and
recognize that the industrialization
that they were so had such an
overweening a sense of pride about was
it's in fact special to them then the
question is is velocity special to them
because that perhaps is the one thing
the u.s. still produces is really high
speeds particularly for the transmission
of information and the dissemination of
that information to innumerable
recipients in that respect I have been
particularly interested in the events of
the Arab Spring
last winter where Twitter and Facebook
and given all sorts of credit for mass
mobilization but that mass mobilization
was not something that was envisaged by
Facebook and Twitter Facebook and
Twitter and visited quite correctly the
idea of you know going into the theatre
now the text you later I mean they were
meant to be social they weren't meant to
be revolutionary and so it may be that
the inventive stage of high-velocity
communication is something that's not
sort of like lithographed looks
something it's not going to occur in the
euro-american point of origin of the of
the software so anyway this is my
argument dealing with power and
technology is this a an era of new power
alignments yeah I would say so but I
would but to me the technological half
of this of the argument of this chapter
folk should focus more on the issue of
velocity than on the end then on the
issue of industrial production the
industrial production creates social
issues that feed into a political arena
and I'll talk about the politics of all
this on Thursday
you